اللي احنا شايفينها دي هي مدينه سيالكوت
في مقاطع اسمها البنجاب في شمال شرق
باكستان مدينه باكستانيه صغيره بيسكنها
حوالي 735 الف نسمه على مساحه 19 كيلو متر
مربع ليه بعرفكم بالمدينه دي لانه لو عندك
كره قدم في البيت ففي احتمال كبير ان
الكره دي مصنوعه في السياحه وده لانها
ببساطه اكبر مصنع تصنيع كرات لعبه كره
القدم في العالم المدينه الصغيره اللي
قدامنا دي يا اخواننا بتنتج 70% من
الامدادات العالميه للقرارات بما فيها كره
كاس العالم 2022 اللي اقيمت الاسابيع اللي
فاتت في قطر وتلاعبه المباراه النهائيه
فيها امبارح نسيب باكستان شويه ونرجع مصر
تحديدا اليوم 21 نوفمبر 2022 هنلاقي في
رئيس الوزراء المصري مصطفى مدبولي بيشيد
ديكورات كره القدم اللي اتصنعت في مصر
لكاس العالم 2022 فقط
نفسنا بنسال شويه اسئله منقيه زي مثلا هي
كرات كاس العالم اللي اتلعب في قطر تصنعت
في باكستان ولا في مصر ويا ترى ايه علاقه
عملقه الملابس الرياضيه العالمي اللي
بيورط كرات كاس العالم للفيفا وهي شركه
اديداس بباكستان ومصر وليه ده انجاز وقبل
ده محتاجين نعرف قصه المدينه الصغيره
الواقعه وسط عشرات المدن الباكستانيه
الفقيره وازاي وصلت للعالميه في مجال
تصنيع كرات القدم عاليه الجوده وبتصدرها
للعالم كله كل ده واكتر هنعرفه مع بعض في
حلقه خفيفه وسريعه النهارده وقبلها
بافكركم بالاشتراك في القناه علشان
تساعدونا نطور من شغلانا وفي نفس الوقت
بافكركم برده ان الحلقه زي كل حلقاتنا
اللي فاتت وترجمه للغه الانجليزيه
[موسيقى]
حلقه دي برعايه البنك التجاري الدولي لو
عندك شركه صغيره او المتوسطه فالكلام اللي
جاي ده لو عاوز تسهل وتطور الجزمه بتاعك
سي اي بيقدم لك مجموعه خدمات حلوه جدا
25 مليون جنيه
مختلفه ثاني حاجه هتقدر تحول مرتبات كل
موظفينك بضغط الزراعه الميزه الثالثه بقى
انسى التعامل بالكاش دلوقتي تقدر تستلم كل
فلوسك من العملاء وتدفع كل مستحقاتك
للموردين بسهوله من خلال رابع حاجه اي
عميل عندك يقدر يحول لك فلوسك من اقرب
مكنه نقاط بيع وهتدخل حساب شركتك على طول
خامس حاجه بقى لو محتاج استشارات للبزنس
بتاعك علشان تكبره وتنميه هتلاقي مجموعه
من الخبارات
في وصف الفيديو والتعليقات فيسبوك صناعه
لعبه كره القدم بيرجع تاريخها الحكمه
الاستعماريه البريطانيه وهنا في قصه محليه
لطيفه ضروري نقولها عن نشاه الصلاه عليه
هناك قبل تقسيم الهند شاق باكستان سنه
1947 كانت المنطقه دي كلها محتله من قبل
البريطانيين وكان بيسكن مدينه سيالكوت
مئات من الجنود الانجليش الروايات المحليه
بتقول انه في يوم من الايام وجنود
البريطانيين كانوا بيلعبوا كره قدم وبعدين
الكره اتقطعت منهم فخدوا الكوره وراحوا
لاسكافي محل بيصلح الاحذيه علشان يصلح لهم
الكوره فلما صلح الكوره بشكل كويس والجنود
كانوا معجبين بشغله وبقى هو اللي بيصلح
لهم الكوره على طول لما تتقطعها وبين مرور
الوقت الاسكافي ده بس بتاع ان شكله الكوره
والمكونات المصنوعه منها وبدا يحاول
يقلدها ولما بقى راضي عن تصميمه وبدا يقنع
الجنود انهم يشتروا منه الكرات مباشره بدل
ما بيجيبوها من الجلساره ومن هنا بدا
الصناعه كرات القدم لو بصينا على نجاح
مدينه صناعتها المحليه المتخصصه في اخر 20
سنه هنلاقيه شئ مولفه جدا لان اتباع وفي
نفس الوقت نادر جدا تكراره في باكستان
اقتصاد بتاعها بيعاني بقى له عقود من ضعف
الصادرات وازمات متكرره في ميزان
المدفوعات يعني وفقا للبنك الدولي في
الصادرات الباكستانيه انخفضت من 17% من
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي سنه 1992 ل 10%
السنه اللي فاتت 2021 ورغم كده بتصمد
مدينه سيادتكم مش بس قدام المشاكل
الاقتصاديه وعدم استقرار السياسي ولكن
كمان قدام التحديات الخارجيه زي صعود
الصناعات الصينيه والتخلي عن العماله
البشريه لصالح الاكماتها القدس ومنها ذلك
قدام كل ده ونجحت في انها تبقى مركز عالمي
لتصنيع قناه القدم وجزمت العلامات
التجاريه الرياضيه الرائده في العالم في
بيئه غير مستقره زي دي دلوقت المدينه فيها
حوالي 1,000 مصر
بيصنعوا ثلثين كرات القدم في العالم
وبيشتغل فيهم ثمانيه في المئه تقريبا من
تعداد سكان المدينه يعني بنتكلم عن 60,000
شخص شغالين في مجال تصنيع كره القدم غرفه
زار المحليه في سيالكوت فالمدينه انتجت
كرات قدم بقيمه 191 مليون دولار في العام
المالي 2021 2022 وغلبيه الكرات اللي
بتتصنع في المدينه بتتعمل من خلال خياطه
اليدويه يعني العامل ممكن اخيط من ثلاث
لاربع كرات في اليوم ورغم انها عمليه شاقه
الا انها بتخلي القوه اكثر متانه وبتمنحها
بمزيد من الاستقرار الديناميكي الهوائي
ولكن مع ظهور عملاق تصنيع بيحدد صناعه
كرات القدم وهي الصين بدات الشركات
الكبيره في السيلكون تلجا للالات المتقدمه
علشان تتغلب على محدوديه الانتاج اليدوي
وتزود الانتاجها الشركه الاكبر في تصنيع
كرات كره القدم عاليه الجوده في مدينه
سيالكوت وفي باكستان كلها هي شركه انتم
عارفين يا اخواننا الناس في جميع انحاء
العالم بيشتروا كام كره قدم في السنه 40
مليون كره قدم شركه بتصنع لوحدها حوالي 15
مليون كره قدم في السنه يعني اكثر من 77%
من اجما كرات كره القدم اللي العالم
بيشتريها كل سنه وبما انها اكبر شركه في
سيالكوت فهي بتعتبر من اكبر مصادر الدخل
في المدينه في العام المالي 21 2022 بلغت
عائداتها حوالي 51 مليون دولار طب ايه قصه
الشركه دي في سنه 1991 تاسست فيورس سبورتس
على ايد مهندس شاب اسمه خواجه مسعود اخطاء
والشركه وقتها كانت عباره عن ورشه صغيره
بتصنع بالكاد 1000 كره قدم في الشعر وبعد
الشغل دهوب على مدار ثلاث سنين جاءت
النقله الكبيره للشركه لما قدرت تكسب ثقه
عملاقه الملابس والادوات الرياضيه
الالماني القديمه اتفاق بينهم سنه 1994
بحيث تكون فلورد مورد ادوات رياضيه
وتحديدا كرات كره قدم عديده لحد سنه 2003
اغلب الكرات اللي بيتم تصنيعها بالشركه
متقاطعه دوائيه ولكن بعدها حصلت ثوره في
الشركه من خلال ما كانت معظم عمليات تصنيع
كره القدم
تطوير المستمر في التصنيع وادخال قناه
الرابطه الحراري بدا انتاج الشركه يتضاعف
وفي 2009 فورد قفزه نوعيه ثانيه لما شركه
اديداس خليتها تصنع الكرات الرسميه للموسم
ده من دوري ابطال اوروبا اللي اتلعب
النهائي بتاعه في اسبانيا سنه 2010 ومن
ساعتها وبقت احد الموردين الاساسيين
الاديداس اللي بيصنعوا كرات كره القدم
عليه الجوده والتقنيه في بطولات كره القدم
المهمه يعني هنلاقي ان عدد من الكرات اللي
بيتلعب بها الدوري الالماني والدوري
الفرنسي من تصنيع فروع الباكستانيه
ودوريات اوروبيه ثانيه برده كرات دوري
ابطال اوروبا وكاس الامم الافريقيه وكاس
العالم 2014 في البرازيل كره الرسميه اللي
هي براسوكا من تصنيع فروع وكوره كاس
العالم 2018 في روسيا اللي هي تلس ستار
برده من تصنيع فاره ورد كره قطر 2022 اللي
هي اسمها الرحله كل البطولات دي واكتر
شركه
طبعا اديداس مش معتمد على الفور ولا
لوحدها في توريد كرات البطولات دي وده
طبيعي لان عديده بس مش عايزه تحط كل البيت
في سله واحده بحيث لو الكرات اللي جايه من
مورد كان فيها مشكله يكون في نسخه
احتياطيه من موارد تاني يعني مثلا كاس
العالم قطر 2022 في شركتين والرجل اديداس
كراته شركه فورويل ده العالميه والشركه
الصينيه ثانيه رفضت اديداس الاعلان عن
اسمها وبالمناسبه دي تعالوا نتكلم سريعا
عن كره الرحله بتاعه كاس العالم اللي لسه
خلصانه امبارح ده هات يا عبده
شركه فور ورد بتقول انها صناعه خمسه ونصف
مليون كره من كرات الرحله في 60 الف كوره
منهم مصنوعه بطريقه عاليه الجوده لانهم
بيستخدموا في المباريات وفي تدريبات الفرق
طبعا دي مش منهم الباقي بيتباع للجمهور في
جميع انحاء العالم الكره مصنوعه بتقنيه
الترابط الحراري والضغط على الاختبارات
صارمه علشان تتوافق مع معايير الفيفا
اختبارات كرويه لضمان الاستداره المثاليه
واختبارات للطيران والارتداد والسرعه
واختبارات مناخيه وغيرها الشيء المثير
والنافس جدا في كره الرحله اللي اتلعبت
بها البطوله انها بتضم تكنولوجيا فائقه
جدا وجديده اول مره بتستخدم في كاس العالم
محطوط جوه الكوره دي مستشعر الحركه هو
وحده قياس بالقصور الذاتي معروفه اختصارا
وده مستشفى شعر بيبعث بيانات لغرفه التحكم
لكشف حالات التسلل مع البيانات الثانيه
اللي بتتباعت من 12 كاميرا التتبع
والمخصصه مثبته تحت سقف الاستاد لا تتبع
الكوره وحوالي 29 نقطه بنات لكل لاعب على
ارضيه الملح طيب دلوقت عرفنا ان نصف كرات
كاس العالم على الاقل مصنوعه في مصانع
شركه فور اورنج باكستان ايه علاقه مصر
بالموضوع بقى يعني هل فعلا في كرات اتلعب
بها بعض المباريات كاس العالم كانت مصنوعه
في مصر في الحقيقه لم يذكر بشكل واضح لا
على موقع الفيفا ولا اديداس ان جزء من
كرات كاس العالم اتصنعت في مصر ولكن في
نفس الوقت ما حصلش نفي منهم لحد لحظه
تصوير الحلقه لحد ما يكون في معلومه واضحه
تماما فاحنا هنا هنعتمد على روايه
المسؤولين المصريين الرسميه بطبيعه الحال
لو انتقلنا من مدينه سيالكوت في باكستان
وترن على القاهره في مصر تحديدا شرق
القاهره هنلاقي مدينه الصناعيه على مساحه
500 و6 فدان بتشتغل في قطاعين دماغه وجود
وهي مدينه روبيك للجلود ودي تعتبر اكبر
مدينه صناعيه للجلود والمنتجات الجلديه في
الشرق الاوسط شمال افريقيا من بين المصانع
اللي موجوده في المدينه هنلاحظ مصنع مقام
على مساحه 3 افلام دينا وش في ال 600 عامل
مصر المصنع ده هو مصنع شركه فور واد ايدج
التابعه لمجموعه فور والباكستانيه وبما ان
فورد هي اللي بتصنع لشركه اديداس كورات
كره القدم في كاس العالم زي ما وضحنا فتم
تصنيع جزء من الكرات اللي اتلعب بها بعض
المباريات كاس العالم في المصنع ده في
مدينه روبيك في مصر احمد النبوي نائب رئيس
شركه فروع ايجيبت بيقول ان العمال
المصريين سافروا باكستان وتم تدريبهم هناك
لمده شهرين قبل بدء عمليه التصنيع وان
الشركه بتعتمد على خبراء باكستانيين
وممثلين عن شركه اديداس العالميه وهنا
المصنع المصري بيستورد التكنولوجيا
والالات من باكستان بالتنسيق مع شركه
الرحله بتاعه كاس العالم 2022 قطر بدات
محادثات تصنعها في مصر من السنه اللي فاتت
وفقا لكلام هشام السيد العضو المنتدى في
الشركه وبدا تصنعها الفعل في شهر فبراير
2022 وبداوا يسلموا الدفعات الاولى من
منتصف شهر نوفمبر 2022
يعني قبل انطلاق بطوله كاس العالم بايام
الشركه المصريه هتكمل انتاج كرات كره
القدم
وبتستهدف انتاج 3.5 مليون كره قدم في
السنه وكمان بتخطط للتوسع ودمج انتاج
الاحذيه والملابس الرياضيه لشركه اديداس
بعد ما تم الاتفاق مع اديداس على تسويق
الانتاج المصري في الاسواق الافريقيه
والاوروبيه في النهايه حابه اقول كل
التوفيق والدعم لاي كيان مصري شغال على
تصنيع اي سلعه او خدمه بهدف التصدييه ودعم
الاقتصاد المصري وعامله ما اختم حلقتنا
السريعه دي عندي سؤال لحضراتكم خلونا نخش
في التعليقات تفتكروا الا ناقص الشركات في
بلادنا العربيه علشان تقدر تنافس عالميا
وتحقق نجاحات وسط الشركات العالميه
الثانيه هتتابع اجابتكم في التعليقات وما
تنسوش تشوفوا خدمات بنك سي اي بي هتلاقوا
رابط لهم تحت الفيديو ويا ريت لو عجبتكم
الحلقه تعملوا لايك وشير للفيديو واهم
حاجه تحكم لاصحابكم عندنا يمكن يستفيد ما
تنسوش تشتركوا في القناه زي ما اتفقنا
سلام
[موسيقى]